it gets very difficult yeah i remember
auditioning for the hobbit
and i auditioned when guillermo del toro
was
was the director audition in london
they loved me then they brought me back
and then it switched and then i you know
i thought i was really close and then i
met with
uh you know peter jackson philippe
boyne's friend walsh
and of course the day i was at shutters
you know super nervous
wanting to audition for that role and i
thought i was you know i could taste it
you know what it's like when you can
taste it yeah and you're like i'm gonna
be filming for two years in new zealand
with peter jackson you know
on the heels of lord of the rings and
and i go up to the room and
i don't see peter jackson because he's
sick in in a bedroom
so i'm auditioning just with fran
boyne's and philip you know philippa
boynes and fran walsh
and it's not the same because of course
you want the energy the
the the the there's almost that that
fear and that excitement that blended
into a perfect like you know
whatever so hoping i was i hadn't
pictured you know you know him working
with me and
nothing against uh philippe boyz and
fran walsh they're both brilliant but
it was just not the same and i know i
did a good job because i
i and uh and you know it didn't work out
because
physically i saw the guy that they they
cast and it was
totally he's i know him and it was
absolutely
evidence that he should get the part but
but it hurt
man and i learned i heard about it
through a friend of my active friend who
said oh my god
he just got the greatest gig he got this
role in the hobbit and i was like
that's the role i was up for and i
literally
were having dinner and i just couldn't
have dinner anymore and i was like you
know what guys
i i i i think i was yeah i went to bed
and it took me like a few days yeah well
it's hard
rejection's hard